Hello?
Okay.
I
think we are good.
Awesome.
Hey, John.
Alright. So
today,
I'm gonna take a look at
monitoring Kubernetes
with InfluxDB.
So a little bit about me, I guess.
I've been
actively using containers in Kubernetes for many years.
I'm a Kubernetes organization member.
I've been working with the release team.
I think I know Kubernetes pretty well.
I know InfluxDB
pretty well.
So today's plan is to try
and put those two
two skills of mine together.
Now I have been trying to focus
my efforts
as I work in FluxDB on
it's making our Kubernetes story a little bit
better.
And a major focus of that at least
over
the last what?
Three months
has been maintaining the helm charts repository.
So we're gonna see how far we can
get using these charts.
Then
we are gonna take a look at another
InfluxDBata
initiative.
Which is our community templates.
I haven't used this Kubernetes template before.
But someone has contributed it.
So we're gonna use the helm charts.
We're gonna get all of the telegraphs running.
We're gonna deploy these dashboards
and we're gonna take a bit of an
objective look at them.
I kind of leverage my experience of both
products, try and identify
what's missing from this template and then we'll
try and contribute that back.
I don't expect it to be complete.
The community templates project is pretty new.
But you know, by doing this, we can
identify what needs to be improved and just,
you know, do it.
There are some telegraph plugins that we're gonna
take advantage of. We'll cover all of that
as we go.
Hopefully
that sounds good.
So what I've done,
what I did,
I'll learn how to speak English.
I'm running mini cube and there's pretty much
nothing here. You can see I've ran, get
pods, all namespaces.
This is a pretty,
pretty new setup.
So we're gonna follow the documentation for the
helm charts
and get the first few components
working.
So step one, we're going to add the
influx data helm repository.
Done.
Nice. Let's hope it's always easy as that.
We don't actually need to search do we?
You know, I know what charts that are,
but
I've never I don't think I've ever run
helm search before so.
Cool.
So the first thing I wanna get
done here is
deploy InfluxDB
two.
Yes. Let's do that.
So
let's fire open code.
What we'll do is
we'll just I like make fails, make fails
make me happy.
I guess I can make this font a
bit bigger.
Go with 24.
Sure won't be too wild.
And we want to deploy
InfluxDB
two
and to do this, we're gonna do a
helm upgrade
install.
Gonna need the name, let's call that InfluxDB
and the chart which will be influx data
slash influx DB.
Let's take a look at the values file
and see if there's anything that we need
to overwrite.
So
I've not modified this chart since March.
So it might make sense to upgrade the
tag.
I believe it might be running the alpha.
We don't want to run the alpha.
And
Oh, it's gonna go with chart app version.
Oh, beta. Nice.
Did I do that?
I did.
Go me. Alright. So back to the values.
So we don't need to touch any of
this. Not gonna put any resource requirements on
it.
I don't mind the user being admin organization.
Yep. Happy with all of that.
We'll go with 50 gigs of persistence. Right?
So I'm not gonna change anything in that.
I'm just gonna deploy it.
So
let's run,
make deploy and FlexDB.
And We wait.
I'm assuming I sound okay. I'm hoping someone
would have said you don't sound okay by
now.
I didn't check the audio but the video
was okay.
I don't recall why it would be holding,
But we can be patient.
What I will do is just gonna split
this and run get NS.
Thank you, John.
And
yeah. So I'm okay with the error just
now that job will retry.
There we go.
So I was just waiting on the setup
job. So InfluxDB,
you you cannot disable the authentication at all.
So the way that we handle that in
the helm chart
is we use a setup job
Which just runs the influx setup command
and it'll retry that until it works. So
even though it fails twice and that's just
because InfluxDB isn't
really running yet. You know, the container started
but there's a few things that have to
happen.
And then the cell works.
Now,
if I want to browse to InfluxDB,
what I will do is just, we're gonna
need that a lot. So I'm just gonna
keep that open here. We'll do a port
forward.
And 0999999
And we'll just leave that quite happy there.
Okay. So,
if we browse,
our username was
admin,
but we need the password.
So let's deal with that. In order to
get the password, we have to pull out
the secret. So we're going to do get
secrets.
And we have influx DB off.
No YAML.
We want
data
admin password.
Let's see if I can override the data
admin
password.
I wish we could have to do the
j q stuff. Is it just quotes maybe?
I'll
try one more time.
Nah. Okay. So we're just gonna be sixty
four. I copied it. So
drop that. Oh, come on. I thought I
copied it.
Password
copy.
Base sixty four.
Paste.
And here is my password.
Awesome. So we have nothing I would imagine.
We do have a default bucket that is
created for us. We've got no dashboards, no
task, there's nothing like that. So
the next step is
we could start loading telegraph in.
So
taking a look at the data
but I think what we'll do is we'll
just pull these dashboards and right away. I
don't think there's any point in those hanging
around.
And even if these don't show us anything
just yet, at least we can get a
rough idea of what we're getting out of
the box with this community template.
So let's do
raw copy of this.
And
if we use
I may just have to blow in old
config, but
have we used Influx package dash dash fail
and point it to this.
And we just need to specify
the
token which are good point. I haven't
Let's grab the token
base to code that.
There we go.
The token just gives me API access. So
we
wanna specify the token
here
and we wanna specify the organization here,
which would influx data.
I guess that doesn't support remote URLs,
which means I'm now gonna curl that.
And
I don't have that in the clipboard anymore.
I wonder if I could just
computer
fail me today as always.
Let's just copy it. And then I'll lose
my token and have to do that again,
but
Alright.
So we probably could just pay the influx
package command,
but I'm sure I'll get something wrong there.
So let's just
let's just download the file and then
copy that token again,
which is nails away.
That didn't work.
I will look up that JQ syntax later
and get annoyed at myself,
but
no biggie.
Talking.
So I will
say here that this is one of the
coolest,
I could have just did that. This is
one of the coolest features we've added to
InfluxDB.
All pretty much single handedly developed by Johnny.
One of the engineers on the tools team.
But it gives you like this declarative interface
to create any resource inside of InfluxDB.
Very similar to the way you would apply
a Kubernetes manifest.
Super awesome.
We get this nice preview. This is all
the stuff that's gonna create. I'm not gonna
go through that. We will just
gonna deploy and and and prod through the
UI.
But if you take a look, okay, if
we just get the syntax highlighting back, you
know, we can create labels and the manifest
format here just as Kubernetes style manifest. The
idea being that eventually there'll be an operator
on Kubernetes where we just support this as
a CRD. At least some of the resources
as a CRD.
It creates dashboard. It's got flux created in
it.
All the UI blah, blah, So what we
should see is that they create any buckets.
No.
No buckets.
Does it create
won't create the holographic scrapers or anything I
would have thought.
Any tasks?
Nope. Any alerts? Nope. So already there's there's
things we can add to this I believe,
but we do have dashboards.
So
we have a cube inventory dashboard
and a node metrics dashboard.
And we have no data but
we expect that for the time being. In
fact, I wonder if they do provide a
telegraph config for scraping this.
There
we go.
We're gonna use the home charts anyway,
but nice that this is provided.
So it's collecting metrics
on
a one minute interval with a ten second
flush.
Okay. I think that can be tweaked. I
don't think that makes a lot of sense,
but
okay.
Alright.
So we want to deploy
Helm charts.
So the Influx
Helm charts do provide
one very opinionated way of collecting metrics and
then one flexible
option. So let's talk about that.
The telegraph DS
is our opinionated
very little configuration
helm chart to deploy
Kubernetes and node based metric collection.
And we have had pull requests and issues
where people want us to add new things
to it, but you know, if you want
to run your own plugins and save the
cluster, you should just use
telegraph.
The DS one is just,
if you want to monitor Kubernetes just use
this chart and it's gonna get you a
pretty good way through it.
Let's see what we get for, get with
this. So let's do deploy telegraph
DS
Throw in this command. I'm happy with all
that. I don't think there's really much to
change here.
Yep. We're gonna run telegraph one fourteen. We're
gonna run Alpine variant.
I'm not fussed about the resource things. We
do need to use the downward API just
to inject the host name.
And that's just so that we can hit
the cubelet
from each node inside of the cluster without
going through the API proxy server
or maybe we do go through that anyway,
but that's irrelevant.
Host IP, some prox stuff,
service accounts and then the config itself,
where it's going to try and write
to
here,
which won't work for us. So we do
need to tweak that.
Okay.
Let's just
double check how this works.
ConfigMap.
There we go. So it enables
so we have the ability to change the
agent, processes,
aggregators and outputs.
There is no possibility to change the inputs
though.
And we do just go through a straight
to the Qplet IP. We don't go through
the API server proxy. So that's good.
May not work on JKE if I remember
correctly though.
So we want to values config outputs.
We wanna modify that to rate the influx
DB two.
So config
outputs. In fact, if we just copy all
of this and delete the stuff that we
don't need.
So telegraph.
YAML.
I will turn on monitor self.
I'm not gonna touch any of this.
We just want to modify this.
We're just gonna go to the InfluxDB
service,
which
should exist.
Didn't do a full name override,
we'll just
drop that in on port nine nine nine
nine. And now actually, yeah, I think the
service that just goes over standard 80,
so we can just take that off.
Database wise, let's well, that's not about setting
for this. What we want is bucket and
we want default.
We
need
our
organization
maybe.
Influx data.
We need token.
And
I'm just gonna hardcore the token for now
but if someone reminds me,
we'll clean that up later.
There is a project I've been working on.
Telegraph,
nope.
InfluxDB
operator.
This
actually allows
if we take a look,
I can't even remember where I put the
fails,
samples.
This allows you to
define an InfluxDB that exists,
you specify the organization ID, you can provide
the root token
and then
anything inside of your Kubernetes cluster can request
additional tokens
for that InfluxDB.
Something that doesn't do just yet is allow
you to scope that token to be just
one or two buckets or just read access
but you know, still a work in progress.
So we can try and drop that in
later but I don't want that to slow
me down right now.
So we need to
add a token.
Got it. So if I find that token
again from just taking a look at,
I'm in a different directory, I switched to
global history
and flux
dash t.
Yeah, let's just get it back. Okay.
YAML.
I don't remember how to JQ
base 64.
I know all my history is randomly showing
up. Switch that back
and there's our token
and back to local history.
So
dropping the token.
Let's just
make sure I've not forgotten
anything. Where did I just put all those
tabs?
So
telegraph.
I just wanna double check the config before
I go applying this and realize I've forgotten
something else. So inputs,
no outputs.
InfluxDB
two.
Talking got URLs got organization got bucket got
perfect.
Token organization bucket URLs,
fix the name,
monitor self.
Let's see what happens.
Let's run get pods.
Telegraph of creatine. Let's run a watch on
that and just wait.
It's running.
Let's grab some logs, make sure it's happy.
It's right into the wrong place.
Helps
if
I tell it to use the values file.
So telegraph
d s
dot yaml.
Let's just update that deployment.
Let that terminate, spin back up
and then pull out the logs one more
time.
Perfect.
So we'll give that ten seconds.
Just wanna make sure we don't get an
error message when it tries to do the
buffer flush.
Looks okay to me. I'm gonna jump over
here
and let's just have a look at the
data. Nice. We have loads of data.
Okay.
So if we wanna take a look at
the CPU,
I should put in few of these or
all of them, I guess.
Five minutes
and data, data, data, data, data.
Okay.
What do our boards look like now?
Okay. So default.
There we go.
So our node metrics dashboard
gives us
node names and node count.
We've got some CPU metrics.
So we don't have a lot of data
just yet.
What are these doing? Allocatable CPU
cores.
So
filters on Kubernetes pulls out this field aggregates
and pulls out the last value.
Well,
maybe that'll pop up later. Nano core distribution
by node.
Not
something
I think
I would find
useful.
Maybe there's a better way we can build
this visualization.
I prefer this one. I think that's a
little better
when we have some more data here.
Nano core distribution.
Me.
Pod capacity.
So I'm assuming that's pulling and
pod per node limit
probably doesn't exist in many cube.
And node current is fine. Memory consumption.
Alright. Perfect.
Let's just break distribution by
node name.
Okay.
File system.
Yep. Everyone needs to know when this is
gonna fill up. We could build on all
that around us for sure.
Nothing worse than being woken up at 3AM.
I've been disconnected there.
And our network consumption. Yeah. Of course. We
need to understand
what's going through the pipes.
Okay.
I think
I mean I mean, it does say Kubernetes
node metrics.
I think the Linux system dashboard
may be a slightly better fit, give us
a bit more information
and
there's nothing really Kubernetes specific here other than
some pod stuff.
So John says the bar interface at least
shows what nodes are above the median load
wise could be good for balance. Yeah.
Fair point.
Alright. Cool. That's the first dashboard.
Next dashboard,
cube inventory. This is actually going to show
us
Kubernetes resources.
I've got this memory and CPU stuff again,
a little bit of duplication.
But we're not actually getting
any Kubernetes stuff.
So this dashboard shows Kubernetes
metrics based on the cube inventory APIs
collected via telegraph cube inventory plugin.
Make sure you have the bucket variable selected,
which I do.
So that we configure
Influx cube inventory
plugin.
Let's just
jump
inside of this pod and
let's go and take a look.
I could probably be a bit faster if
I just put up the help me pull,
but
okay. Right. So we don't enable cube inventory
on this. Actually, that makes sense. Right. This
is a daemon set deployment and the cube
inventory plug in, we only want one off.
So let's get that deployed.
So deploy
telegraph.
We'll call this telegraph Kubernetes. We may have
more telegraphs. I think there'll be other stuff
that we want to deploy to.
So we're gonna deploy
telegraph Kubernetes.
I hate
shortening it to Kate's but
brevity I think is gonna be my friend
here.
And we'll have this
and we'll have this. We're gonna create
a telegraph
Kubernetes.
We're gonna jump over to the helm charts
again.
So this time we wanna take the hello.
I'm correct. The telegraph chart that allows us
to inject pretty much any configuration that we
want.
Now if we open the values file here,
yes, we're only gonna want one for this.
We're gonna use the same image.
Probably disabled that. I don't know why that's
there. It's probably been there since before the
charts were under influx data control or at
least maintenance, not control. That was a horrible
way to say that.
We've got
volumes
here. Oh, yeah. I fixed this recently because
it didn't work.
So an older volume and key was previously
added which will likely not work as you
expect. It doesn't work at all. Please use
this New York configuration. So we can inject
our own config. Good.
Our back stuff, service accounts. We've got config,
config, config.
I don't know why. I don't know why
you'd wanna do that. I'm sure this a
use case I can't think of right now.
So this is the default
really. Well, I mean, I don't know why
stats d is
running as a default configuration,
but let's just ignore that for now and
let's copy
this.
So what we want to deploy here,
I'm not thinking off the top of my
head that I want this to be easier
for people that wanna monitor Kubernetes clusters. I
think the telegraph DS one is great because
no configuration is really required.
Except for just telling it where to write
the metrics too.
I think maybe there should be another
chart or maybe we should just provide a
values
Kubernetes or something here.
So that just says this is your this
is the one that you use for getting,
you know, Kubernetes resources metrics. I don't know.
Anyone get any thoughts on that? I'd love
to hear that.
So let's copy
this which is normally a bad idea. I
hate copying stuff but again,
an interest of not boring the hell out
of these.
Let's copy.
We can just nuke all of this.
Oh, did I go to far?
We can just add output for ourselves.
And put wise,
don't care for stats d. What I do
want is cube inventory.
And what I'll add is I
really dislike this name when the plugin launched
and then tried to get it changed. It's
just I've never heard anyone in the Kubernetes
ecosystem
refer to it as an inventory. Maybe like
from Ansible chef
puppet
backgrounds,
but just not in Kubernetes. I tried to
get it named cube resources or something, but
I lost that fight maybe another day.
So how do we configure
that?
Let's go inputs
cube
inventory.
We,
you know, wanna grab a URL.
Need to change that
namespace.
We wanna do all. We'll leave that blank.
Better talking path.
Yep. I think I've been trying to get
that set as a default for a long
time,
but not yet.
At least I got a comment at the
time.
There we go.
What else?
We're gonna include everything.
What I'm going to do is I'm pretty
sure I've configured this before
and my InfluxDB examples repository
where I have a full end to end
Kubernetes thing here that I'm trying not to
use today.
But I
think
it may be useful just to double check.
So
this is how I configure it normally.
Don't know why I'm turning them to blank.
I'm sure there's a reading.
Kubernetes defaults.
Fine. Open. Fine. There was something else, wasn't
there?
Wait. I'm thinking of the Gelps example.
There's a new flag added to this plugin.
I thought I was trying to remember what
it was.
Maybe.
Tell you what. Let's do
you know what? That's not important.
Alright.
We never got a reminder of what that
was anyway. We have the key. I guess
that may work.
And
we're going to should
be okay.
Yeah. So the flag that was added to
the telegraph Kubernetes plugin allows you to actually
extract
annotations
from the resources and apply them as tags
on the metrics.
We
may need that, but I can always look
it up when we do rather than
pondering it at the moment. So let's confirm.
Okay. So many queue pass
is self signed
certificate
and secure skip verify.
I don't know if this
Yeah. Let's try to find it. I think
it might be safer
and then reapply.
So
we're on one.
Get pods,
run a watch,
error. Okay. Destrangify quick go
and watch.
No. It's running. Okay.
Logs,
telegraph,
kits.
Okay. So now we've got our back hell.
Let's double check the config there.
Does it not create the RBAC
by default?
Does.
Okay.
Let's
take a look at the part.
And we want to know
the service
cat.
So it's running with telegraph kits.
Let's take a look at
service
account.
Is it a cluster or namespaced?
Sorry, it's against our always namespace. Do.
Alright. What we actually care about is the
binding.
So okay.
Is it gonna be cluster rule?
Oh, wait. Okay.
Let's just enable that.
Yes. This is our one super telegraph
cluster wave monitoring thingy.
Maybe I should just get you out of
way. There we go.
I don't know what that's gonna do. Now
that I've changed that to be Is it
gonna delete the
role binding and create the cost of role
binding?
Who knows?
Let's try role bindings.
Done.
That's the rule bindings.
Cool.
Nice job.
Nice job, Helm. Not me, obviously.
Logs. Okay. Let's see.
Alright. So we still got some permission problems.
Is that just because the pod needs re
yep.
We just need to put the pod.
So
hopefully,
we just need to put the pod.
And
k logs,
telegraph,
Kubernetes.
Okay.
So that now has a cluster role binding,
but still doesn't have the permissions.
That can be nicer.
Maybe that's me now leaning towards we should
have a
a telegraph DS
for the node based stuff and then a
telegraph
Kubernetes
for the cluster wide stuff.
Yeah. I think that would probably make a
little bit of sense.
Okay.
Let's
see what is on this cluster rule binding.
So cluster rule binding,
telegraph Kubernetes,
Yamalet.
So it is a cluster role called telegraph
k, so probably
could have guessed that.
And it has
nothing.
Okay.
So what does this comment say? Maybe that
would have been useful
when using Prometheus to input that when using
the Prometheus input to strip all the pods,
then you need to be have the permissions,
yada yada yada.
So that gives us nodes, node proxy,
node metrics,
services, endpoints, pods,
inquiries.
I mean, it looks like there's still a
few things they're missing that I would want.
So I wonder, do I have an R
back policy here
that I'm happy to steal?
Telegraph yamo,
just a demon set.
We've config.
Chris
are back in here.
Been too long.
Telugu service account,
cluster role.
That's the everything permission. That's the just do
it button. So I mean, we'll start there.
Obviously,
I'll tidy that up when I do make
a chart to make this
easy.
And if I want to apply that then
we need rules
here.
So rules.
Oh, I already had rules. Okay.
There we go.
So all API groups already sources.
I mean, doesn't definitely doesn't need that. Probably
get away with less than gap, but
in the interest of
time, let's
push the go button.
Now that we have our new super role,
I'm assuming just need to
flush that.
Let's see where we are now.
Okay.
When in doubt, forget our back exists.
Let's hit refresh here.
What do we got?
So
parts and replicas.
Interesting label.
So
it is
looking at the Kubernetes deployment measurement, filtering on
the replicas available
and then just grabbing the latest value.
So if we just run that manually,
see what we're dealing with here.
View raw data
and we can just see this reports one
available, one available, one available.
Maybe I was too quick to leave that
dashboard but I guess really what I wanna
know is
there's one available but how many do I
want?
Like, am I one available of six requested?
So
and there's there's there's none of that information
just is not there for me on the
dashboard.
So that's definitely something that I think can
be improved.
I don't I actually
it's of no interest to me how many
pods
are running in my cluster. I mean, as
that number grows, it just becomes less and
less useless useful.
And when we got when we start talking
about horizontal pod auto scaling like
nobody can look at this dashboard and go,
oh, there's 324
pods. That's exactly what I wanted. Like
so that's I think one
of the glaring things we wanna fix right
away. The pod capacity many cube obviously does
set us here. So it's a 10 per
node.
I mean,
I guess really what I wanna see there
is
how close to that am I? I guess
one to a 10.
Maybe these two could just be merged into
a single thing like how much how much
what is my window here? Where's my ceiling?
Sorry. Like when am I when am I
gonna run out of capacity? It's probably a
little bit more important to me.
We have three running what?
Pause and replicas one running pods.
Replica cabin. Okay. I just I don't think
I like any of this. And so let's
I think we'll start building our own dashboard.
I I guess it's the use case of
the of the dashboard. I don't wanna get
into
I'm I'm not a fan of dashboards. I
think dashboards are a debugging tool.
They probably shouldn't be on your wall. It's
something that you look at. What I'm getting
about this is it's
this is something you look at dashboard and
not a shit's on fire and I need
to fix this quick dashboard.
Maybe
there is definitely people that would really like
to see this information.
I just don't think I'm one of them.
Demon sets. Right. Okay. And then we've got
this repeated notes stuff.
PVC stuff is definitely
really important to monitor in Kubernetes.
Unbound stuff to me is more important. I'd
probably just wanna see a list of PVCs
aren't being used and I wanna know why
they're not being used.
And the capacity
like
how close is that to being full? Like
I I I don't have that front and
center.
That's something to me that would be really
important.
Okay. We've got work to do and
we're forty five minutes in.
Okay.
So I'm curious, I'm not even sure how
many people are on the stream
But give me your thoughts on on on
where we are, what these dashboards present to
you, what you want to see from them
and we'll and we'll put this together. We'll
we'll get a really good Kubernetes dashboard.
So
step number one for me is,
well let's create a dashboard.
What do I consider
to be a good dashboard?
So
Kubernetes.
Buyer.
Why didn't I Oh, why didn't I inject
buyer?
Maybe it just doesn't like put into the
give me fire.
Why is my plug in not working?
It works there.
I can't even have to copy that manually.
Alright.
Fire. I'm good. Okay.
So in order to make
right now we have a healthy cluster.
So that means I should be able
to just add a single stat
that returns the number zero
that is showing me that there's nothing that
is expected or scheduled to be running that
is in a build
state.
To me that's important.
If we run get pods all namespaces,
everything is is pretty happy.
Excuse me.
Okay.
Let's have a look at the metrics metrics
that we've got collection right now. I'm not
sure if this is gonna be complete. We
may have to add a few things,
but let's see what we get with pod
container.
State code sounds like it could be useful.
And we have a state code of zero
and that strikes me as potentially being in
enum.
So
I'm not gonna close that community template. So
I'm gonna come back to that. I wanted
to play it to learn a system template
because we still wanna understand the
VM or the bare metal underneath.
So let's
go take a look at the
curb inventory
plugin to see if there's some information
on that enum, if it's an enum.
So state
oh,
state code.
Yep.
Well,
I mean, I know it could be zero.
Thank you.
Okay.
So we're gonna add document. I wish I
had a pen and paper now. Alright. I'm
also gonna add documentation to this to describe
what those state codes are.
Really weird that they seem to do that
for PV and PVC,
just not anything else.
Okay.
So let's see
what's the best way to deal with this.
Get pods, telegraph kits
blah blah blah dash o yamo,
grab dash I.
Okay, let's get a few more lines there.
Did I do that wrong?
So where is that state code?
State test,
State running.
Okay. So zero potentially
means running.
Let's
go Kubernetes Kubernetes.
Search for running.
Maybe that was a bit of a loyal
guess.
Sometimes I forget just how big the Kubernetes
repository is.
Let's try
start to proceed code.
State.
Alright.
We'll get there. Let's take a look at
pod here.
Okay. So it's using
Kubernetes
library.
Let's go to state code.
Ah, we have it here.
Zero running,
terminated
and waiting.
Alright. So if the state code,
I mean terminated.
Yeah. Maybe there's some maybe it's useful to
know how many have been terminated in the
last window.
If that's consistently high,
would be an indicator something's going wrong.
But let's focus on, we have a pods,
duck and a waiting date.
Probably
to me that's a high priority. It's definitely
maybe a problem there if something is waiting
for too long.
So
let's
jump over here. What we wanna see, let's
jump down to the script editor and
we wanna see how many pods are waiting.
So state code two.
We're gonna filter
and we only want to see
value equals
two, which should be none right now.
We wanna count.
We wanna count of total.
And so there's something in flux you need
to do before you do something like a
count or any other
aggregate is just flatten the table structure.
In fact, let's see if we can demonstrate
that.
Yeah, okay. So here we have table zero
and the tables change whenever the series key
changes.
You can see here that's the InfluxDB
pod and this is the Kubernetes pod.
So we need to flatten the tables.
We probably only want the last value of
each two.
So let's
add the last.
We should get one entry per table.
Three tables, three pods.
Group into a single table.
And then run account.
Three.
Take off the raw data. Let's go single
stat.
And call this
waiting
pods
and update the status.
That's because we have a zero.
No data.
What do how do we show a zero?
You know, I'm not
let me think about that.
Waiting pods, no results.
I mean, I would prefer it was a
nice green zero, but for now,
let's stick with that.
Now let's
do something similar,
but I want to
graph the terminated pods over time.
And we see our job.
So
flat lane,
we
know
what that is. We know that that is
a job that's on a setup, it's finished,
it's not coming back. I'm okay with that.
Alright. We have a few comments
from Leo. So he says there are two
types of dashboards.
Contains things I would generally configure alerting for
effectively a dash that shows you how broken
things are. Yes. I like dashboards that show
me how broken things are. Definitely.
And takes them to details and helps debugging.
Yep. Couldn't agree with both of those.
So two is a higher level look.
Yep. So I I call them signals and
signal dashboards.
I still wouldn't wanna look at them though.
They would be purely for alerting.
In fact, if you have alerting rules, you
probably don't need the dashboard specifically and I
would probably lean towards only having debuggy dashboards,
ones that present information to me, correlations between
logs, metrics, etcetera.
I'll think about that a little bit more.
A common thing you had in your cluster
is running out of resources at some point
often due to no yeah. So no drawovers
obviously rather painful.
You've mentioned there isn't preemptible nodes. I'm assuming
that's a GKE,
GKE based on that language.
Yeah. I have I have run Kubernetes clusters
with preemptible nodes. It's
it's cheap,
but you definitely have to handle with a
high rotation of pod churn
as it gets rescheduled a lot.
Cron jobs and pending start, new one created
each minute, jobs never catch up and suddenly
you've got 1,500 unschedulable
pods
because we've had three jobs scheduled every minute
with three resources.
Yeah. It sounds like I understand why you're
running on preemptible nodes, but you may wanna
run multiple node pools there. You wanna affect
node capacity pool that can be hot. That
can be auto scaled when the preemptible system
there.
But it's cool. Sounds really interesting some of
the stuff you're doing. And I think our
thoughts and dashboards are pretty similar.
Alright. Let's try and get some more information
out of this.
Let's go see this fucker here. I'll
try and make my language.
So what do we wanna do? Let's let's
get some failures.
Yeah. Let's let's break some stuff. So
there was a repo shared earlier.
Iain from container solutions.
And it's just Kubernetes examples and it's supposed
to be showing like patterns of how to
deploy certain things, how to use certain features.
But what I really liked about the repository
was just all the broken things on it
so that you can actually learn how to
debug this. And I actually wanna deploy a
few of these broken things and then make
sure that we have dashboards that put that
information front and center.
We're about an hour and just now if
I'm pretty sure we're gonna be running
more than one of these sessions.
But I'll go for a little bit longer.
I can't remember if I have calls today.
Oops. If I do.
Okay.
Now I've already
cloned this repository
because I thought it was really cool.
So we're gonna go to get hub in
examples
and
let's deploy
broken in a container and then make sure
we have enough
metrics
to be able to alert on that eventually.
I don't think we're gonna get around to
alerting today but definitely if we can get
a dashboard component done,
then we have the queries to do the
alerting. So
broken in it.
And just let me throw this out here
again. I I I don't even know how
many people are watching but
if you've got any this is this, this
was to getting started to Kubernetes monitoring with
InfluxDB.
Now I think we've done a fair amount
of stuff here. We've deployed telegraph as a
daemon set. We've got another telegraph running for
some Kubernetes resources stuff. We've got InfluxDB provisioned.
We have brought in the Kubernetes
package or community template. I think we can
make a lot of improvements to that and
I think we'll have a maybe a a
two hour session where we just build out
those dashboards and all our team roles and
then contribute that back to the repository.
But if there's anything that hasn't been covered
today
that you have in your head that you're
you want to know how to do, just
drop me a message now and we'll get
to it over the next, I don't know,
fifteen, twenty minutes. See what happens.
Alright.
Let's take a look at broken containers then.
So
what have we got in this one?
So it's a straight up pod.
From a metrics point of view, I don't
want to
it would be good to be able to
highlight the fact there was a deployment
that was
missing
scheduled resources
even though the pause specifically is broken. So
I probably convert this.
And I remember how to do that deployment
apps v one
spec
template
spec.
Think that's all it should require. There'll be
selectors on there.
What am I missing?
Replicose
one.
Select her
match labels,
Which means we need labels.
Let's call this
broken app
in a container.
Which means if you want a broken app.
Oh, what's going on?
And a container.
What else am I missing?
We'll just try and apply it and see
what happens. Okay.
So this is
a, an a container busy box
that is trying to look up a host
name. It doesn't exist.
So I guess in order to fix this,
we would have to deploy
these
pods and a container service nonexistent service to
the namespace
which would satisfy it from being broken.
Although I'm not particularly interested in fixing it
so
no resource limits. Yes. Versus code. I don't
care.
Shush.
After joining, sleep, sleep, sleep.
That's what?
An hour?
Yeah. Math is the very much strong point.
Okay. Let's deploy it.
We'll just spin open. I've had just gonna
spin up on my location.
Yeah. Okay.
Let's apply it from here.
Apply dash f.
Go.
Selector does not match template labels.
I only I only labeled this.
So we need
labels.
What template
spec label? No.
Oh,
there we go.
Try again.
Wait. Okay. So
if that's gonna stick
and and at zero one
until it has crashing
state. So can
we
see that from this dashboard?
My thoughts are no.
Can we see this
by just exploring
our metrics?
So we have a deployment.
Replicates unavailable.
Let's just break this down to five minutes.
So it's not unavailable yet.
Oh no, wait. It is. Cool.
Just a very
large graph for two very small values.
Set a max on this.
If one remembers how to do that.
No. I don't wanna say inquiry.
So I set a max. Wait. What?
Auto.
Alright. Okay. I don't know what I changed
but
Okay. So now we can see this purple
line. We do have something unavailable. So we
do
we have a way to
stick something on a dashboard that says
there's stuff that you need to fix right
now.
So best way to visualise this.
Probably just a single step for now.
And what we wanna do
is
filter
on the value again.
And if it's larger than zero,
let's just take a look at the raw
data.
Then we get a table per deployment.
We
only
care about the last value for now. Now
I don't think that's ideal.
Probably
better
if
I see how much that value has changed
over the last
five minutes.
But we'll we'll graph that next. Right now,
just want this one cell that says hey,
something doesn't something isn't working
and then if we put a graph next
to that then we wanna be able to
see whether the number of unavailable replicas is
rising,
staying steady
or decreasing.
Because it could be that this thing is
fixing itself and we just need to be
a little bit more patient. We should see
the graph coming down as it goes from
five unavailable replicas down to zero.
If it's stagnant at one, three, four, five,
whatever, then we know there's a consistent problem
and if it's rising, then, you know, we
have probably have a cascading problem and those
are very different situations and scenarios where you
probably wanna adjust the way that you're gonna
try and fix that.
Okay. So if we put the last value
per table
and we then wanna flatten it and we
won't wanna just do a global count.
Okay.
Probably better to do a sum here actually.
So I'm gonna deploy more of these broken
things. We don't wanna count that there's two
broken deployments. I actually wanna see how many
pods
aren't working. And actually maybe there's maybe there's
value in seeing both of those. So maybe
we'll duplicate the cell as well.
So
come back to you. We have a dashboard.
Let's save this to our we have a
sale. Let's save this to our new dashboard.
Kubernetes fire.
We're gonna call this
so deployment
replicas
unavailable.
Yes, computer.
I'm on computer.
I don't know if I should just be
really like
not very patient and just
go away.
It doesn't even take me to the right
dashboard.
Right.
Okay. Deployment records unavailable. I'm going to clone
this.
I also wanna see across how many deployments
are affected.
So
deployments
affected.
What we're gonna do is to count instead
of the sum.
So while these numbers are the same just
now,
they wouldn't, they wouldn't always necessarily be the
same.
So
let's
let's try and do it like this.
And because
I don't like that being blurred because this
is bad.
We'll add some thresholds here. So if the
value is greater than zero,
I mean, it's just gotta be red.
Deployments affected seem like I mean, I guess,
greater than zero
red
and we'll have
green of it zero.
Let's change both of these green. Where's the
honeydew I used? I think so. Okay.
So something's broken. We know that.
What do we wanna see now?
So we can see how long it's been
broken.
Oh, wait. That's a waiting. Yeah. That's a
terminated path.
Yeah. Okay.
I can't even remember what we're doing there.
I'm gonna ignore that.
I can't ignore it.
State two.
If I just not change the number here.
Yeah.
There we go.
Okay. Now we can see it better. Okay.
So now we know
let's
ramp this up a little bit. So
I just wanna make sure we can visualize
this from the right perspective
because this is such a contrived scenario right
now.
We wanna say scale this up to three
and I'm just gonna copy and paste this.
And I'm going to do
what a two here.
We'll call this two two two
two.
We're gonna apply that fail.
It gives me two broken deployments.
I can't remember how many pods I said.
I think it was five broken pods.
Let's just turn on this as a five
second refresh. Hopefully
within the next five seconds.
See see something happen as we, you know,
we're trying to improve our our visibility and
observability here. Good.
So five pods
need action
to effective deployments
and five pods unavailable.
And
we're not getting anything here.
Two two two two two.
So
the problem layer,
if we view the raw data,
this table zero gives us a two to
two.
And the value is just a status code.
Alright. So that's a problem. We actually wanna
know how many
pause are to it. So pull in the
last value,
let's do a group and
I don't know if we want a summary
account just yet.
10 seems wrong.
Five seems good.
Yeah. Some would be a count of the
summon up to five to the status codes.
I don't want that.
Because I'm doing the last, we're not actually
graphing this data anymore. So actually what we
want is an aggregate window.
So what we want is here.
So do I could go window with a
count
over
period.
Zero zero zero
five.
Let's take a look at five minutes.
What have I done wrong here?
Okay. Let's take a look at the
data again.
Oh, we've got states to states to states
to like that.
That makes sense.
Should be,
Let's bring in the last again and we've
got five tables.
And
these are all the pods that are currently
broken.
So I can't aggregate when I'm Oh, because
I'm doing the last. Of course.
So
if you just flatten that group and do
an aggregate window with account.
Yep. That's what we want.
Oh.
Why have I not got tame
on my x axis?
Okay.
Yeah. So that's the one broken pod that
we had. We created this broken pod here
and we then spun that up to five.
I'm not sure why
I will
why it's magically fixed itself.
It has not magically fixed itself.
It's not five containers.
Maybe that's just a bug because this window
is a part window at the moment.
Try refreshing.
Okay.
Yeah. It's definitely drawing on new values up
here. I don't know why it decides that
part window should be written
down there.
Can look into that later.
Alright. So now we have a dashboard that
has a bit more useful information.
If I broken pods,
We can see its effects in two deployments
but what we don't
have an understanding of is just
is just why.
Cool.
So
my next steps here would be I want
to
somehow display
if we do get pods.
Put out one of these broken ones.
And we have events.
Maybe I need to run describe
Describe pod broken
five
seven.
So we're just gonna need logs, aren't we?
Started container.
I was hoping there would be a little
bit more information
there.
Let's look at the gap again.
Because if there's anything I can pull out,
I'm gonna display it.
State
reason.
Okay. So we want do we have that
data first? If not, we need to change
it so we do.
So I'm gonna come back into explore.
Let's go back down to this pod
container.
We have terminated reason. We don't state reason.
Complete.
Alright. So that's a challenge. I really want
this string.
I want it.
This is handy too. It tells me that
I have a problem in a container. So
pod initializing
gets me on the right path.
This is definitely very useful.
So it may be that we need to
start making a few tweaks to the telegraph
plugin.
So
yeah, we don't want the terminated reason. There
must be something else here we can get
access to.
Yeah. And I thought that's really being logged
right now. So I think
in the next session,
we'll maybe try and improve this gather pod
container stuff.
Alright. Let's try and
finish today's stream with something useful. Let's take
a look at these community templates. So I'm
gonna save all of this stuff.
I'm gonna
obviously persist this. I'll store it on my
GitLab repository.
I'm gonna do this specific
Kubernetes stream
probably
twice a week and we're just gonna keep
improving the situation here and working on these
dashboards. I think the next thing I wanna
do is get that extra information from the
pod. I really
I
I really wanna see this somewhere in my
my event log.
In fact, I think most of that is
is useful. So I just wanna see this
and I wanna make sure that we're getting
this reason, the state reason
available as well so that we can have
a little table here that actually filters
the state reasons on the broken pods.
Because when I'm debugging this situation, I see,
oh shit, I've got two broken deployments that's
affecting five pods.
It's been like this for a while. I'm
gonna fix itself.
And I I wanna get as much information
as I can front of the center here
so I know how to go fix that.
And then I can just say, oh, well,
a developer's pushed a broken AI container that's
never gonna satisfy. So that that's next.
Today,
let's pull in this Linux system template
and see what we have here too.
Because this this community templates is a really
big initiative within the company. We have a
lot of contributors are really helping push these
templates forward and, you know, it would be
nice to contribute to that as well.
So raw
and I've not had any questions. I was
hoping someone would have specific questions I could
answer before I started
going off on a little tangent.
So Linux system. YAML.
I still have an influx package command or
not because I'm in their own directory.
Grab that token.
Alright. And there we go.
I'm just gonna point it to that repository.
So code source, get hub, Ian Kubernetes
And
probably download it and there
because of course that's the
best place to put it.
Why is that not working?
Yeah. Logger put in InfluxDB.
Hell yeah. We're definitely gonna be doing that.
There is a
fluent bit plugin
for InfluxDB two.
And if you all wanna stay a bit
longer, I'm happy to get that deployed.
I mean, the plugin list would be handy.
Let's go to the docs. Okay.
So that time where's my port forward?
Don't know what happened there.
Alright.
Plugins.
So
there's actually two really there's two
options we can do for for getting logs
here.
One of them is is here.
Or is that just InfluxDB one? I'm sure
there was changes for InfluxDB two. I'll find
it. There's also vector
dev,
which someone contributed to plug in for two
and I've been looking for any excuse to
start playing with this tool. So maybe that
would be awesome.
Don't get too fussy Leo. I'm gonna filter
the logs for you. That's your job.
Components
and flux
data.
Perfect.
And v two.
So I've been looking for any excuse to
play with this vector dev log timber tool.
I think what we'll do is we'll hook
this up because
sources Kubernetes as here
Somewhere.
Docker.
There is a Kubernetes button.
I'll find it. And it also gives you
I'm not gonna do your work for you.
I'll help you though.
It also gives you this really cool middleware
layer where you could do transformations on the
data enrichment.
So definitely on the next session, you know,
maybe tomorrow
I'll
see
what people are seeing on Twitter, what they
want me to do but
I'm here to serve.
Vector dot dev allows us to get those
logs, enrich them and store them at Influx.
So I think that would be a really
cool session where we sat down and look
at how we actually use that and then
get those logs displayed next to it and
there is a fluent, maybe it was fluent
D that InfluxDB two plugin was for.
I'm gonna have to find that as well.
That's let's do that later. We're now approaching
an hour and a half and I know
these sessions can be really tiring and
a little bit of fatigue kicks in around
this mark, as you've all got real jobs
to do as well. And it has to
die.
Alright. So let's take a look at this
Linux system template.
So we pulled this and on the right
bucket, we're filtered by our only host. So
I actually think this is much more valuable
than what we were getting out of the
box
with the Kubernetes node one. This is a
more
I mean, this is the kind of view
I would expect to see from a Linux
system point of view. Want the memory usage
front and center. I wanna be able to
see, you know, the CPU load over time.
I wanna be able to break that down.
I've got desk and activity here. This was
must've been me pulling images.
You know, we've got some network bandwidth.
It should have been a bit more flatter
than that probably, but you know, this is
a nice look at the Linux system and
you've got to remember that when you're monitoring
Kubernetes, right, there's very there are a lot
of Kubernetes components that you wanna monitor but
you're monitoring the metal first, the VM first.
That has to be healthy for your workloads
to be healthy and then we get into
the workload stuff. So, you know, we've got
this template.
I'm I'm not sure where the value in
these two as yet,
but we're gonna continue to work on our
Kubernetes fire dashboard.
Hopefully tomorrow and we'll get those logs there
and we'll understand what is going on here.
Right now we've got enough to alert for
sure. If this deployment is affected, there's more
than zero or the replicas
are unavailable. It's more than zero for more
than five minutes, maybe less.
Definitely wanna send a trigger.
So next steps.
Get a lot of data and
and ratchet with Kubernetes information as much as
you can and then trigger an alert to
Slack or some HTTP endpoint.
And I think we will do this tomorrow.
I'm keen to continue with this,
but thank you for joining me.
This was the getting started
part
of monitoring Kubernetes with InfluxDB.
Like I said, we'll do this session frequently
and we're just gonna go deeper and deeper
down the rabbit hole. I do expect us
to have to write a lot of code.
I'm gonna have to write a lot of
code. I do think that our telegraph plugins,
there are room for improvement. I definitely wanna
get these statuses on as well. So
we'll cover that next time. Thank you very
much. I hope you've enjoyed this and I
will speak to you soon. Adios.